you know I finished up Celebrity
Apprentice I finished I came home I had
a book of my reading list that was a
Daniel Kahneman's Thinking Fast and Slow
I opened it up started reading and
realized I was reading kind of two
things at once an explanation of what
I'd gone through on Celebrity Apprentice
and the best magic book I ever read I
don't think Daniel Kahneman knew he was
writing a magic book I don't think he
knew he was running about Celebrity
Apprentice but he might have when I was
on Celebrity Apprentice I would see
people who I knew fairly well I would
see them acting in ways that I found
wrong for their personalities
inappropriate I found embarrassing at
times and I couldn't figure out why when
you're outside of the whole thing you
say well they must be giving them a lot
of alcohol which alcohol is always
available but most people on my team
didn't drink so that doesn't work so
maybe you're telling people that crazy
because it'll make better TV that wasn't
happening either and no one ever talked
to me about that and then I read and
this is not Kahneman's work he was
quoting someone else he just kind of
brought it together for me he talked
about a ego depletion ego exhaustion and
it turns out that if you just put
cameras on someone like you're doing to
me here and you ask them to talk they
will speak a little clearer a little
better a little more carefully than they
would if there were no cameras around
but that only works up to a point and we
tend to think of or I always tended to
think of I don't talk about anybody else
I always tend to think of some willpower
as a character trait my mom would talk
about you know Pam you have to have
willpower not a willpower you have
self-control was very very important to
my family very important and I thought
of as a character trait this is
something that maybe I'm born with some
of it but I also want to develop and the
mind-blowing thing about thinking fast
the slow reading that book was that it
is no
not a character trait it is not a
quality it's a it's a muscle the ego the
sensor that the the thoughtful part of
us that controls us the self-control is
something requires effort and a lot of
effort and after you've used that for a
while if they if you make someone very
very careful about what they say for
hours they walk by a piece of chocolate
cake and they're on a diet they'll still
eat the chocolate cake when I was on
Celebrity Apprentice with the cameras on
me all the time and carefully watching
my move I did not make any attempt to
eat healthy cheeseburger french fries
every single lunch I just don't have the
energy to use my self-control that way
and for me when my ego breaks down when
self-control goes away I actually get
very quiet what I tend to do is shut up
and if you watch Celebrity Apprentice as
the day goes on I am less provocative I
am less confrontational when I am
well-rested and working and full of self
control
I am very aggressive it's what I do for
a living when I get tired I get quieter
I don't have conflicts with people I
have to push to be an asshole other
people who are very very nice and his
images were very nice I mean they're
their public image is very pleasant and
sweet after these cameras were on them
you know four five six hours all of a
sudden that what I'm calling a muscle
that self-control would just be
exhausted and they would just spew out
anything was popping into their heads
really angry squabbling and yelling and
pressure and it was a fascinating way to
look at it it never crossed my mind that
what was happening was not some sort of
mental
illness but simply a kind of lack of
self-control caused simply by this ego
exhaustion which is very different I'm
not saying that well the way I
understood Kahneman's book or this
section of the book is is not that they
were physically tired or even mentally
tired but that self-control that ego
part was tired that part that says you
will kind of want to do this but you
should probably do that it was
fascinating and I the first thing I did
when I read the Daniel Kahneman book was
I bought copies for all the producers on
Celebrity Apprentice and senator I said
oh by the way this is what you're doing
you know it's very funny that Kahneman
talks about all these studies that have
been done where they put people in a
room with TV cameras and had them do
tasks to watch how they acted and said
you know they could have just saved a
lot of time they could have just turned
on the television almost every show is a
reality show and they're all based on
that technique that that kind of anti
Hawthorne effect that after you're
watched for a little while you do better
and then it all falls apart
you